earlier this week you may have heard
about this a cross-country Delta flight
ran into trouble when all the plane's
toilets stopped working yeah they
stopped working so apparently the pilot
flew hundreds of miles out of the way
made an emergency landing in Montana
just so his passengers could relieve
themselves yeah Wow
that pilot sounds like a real hero well
I wouldn't say hero just doing my job
ma'am
kind of like Sully Sullenberger except I
didn't get drunk and kill a bunch of
geese I'm sorry sir I don't think
anyone's comparing this to Sully
Sullenberger all right and I'm guessing
you're the pilot
oh great first interview question yes I
am captain Darren Denon Durnin and thank
you for having me on your show Conan
this is not an interview you just got a
ticket like everybody else here in the
audience well you know it's not every
day you get a real live hero on your
show right Darren Dan and earn and how
you doing hero pilot how are you good to
meet you
hey I'm the hero pilot of it right okay
listen oh don't shake his hand please
people
stop it you might be leaning into this
hero thing
a little too hard you basically just
rerouted a flight so your passengers
could take a bathroom break is that
right a life-saving bathroom brick
I saw the crisis and with split-second
reflexes and steely courage I did what
had to be done
it's a miracle there were only three
casualties
wait a minute how did three people die
well it's always hard to know you know
there are so many factors but if I had
to guess it was probably because I was
flying the plane upside down I mean you
were doing white you were playing it was
upside down yeah I was flying the plane
upside down it was either that or right
side up now who wants to see a computer
simulation of my miracle in Montana I do
oh you do no one they really want to see
it Conan okay roll it
Wow
chills am i right no that was that was
just sad admit you're taking a basic
plane rerouting and then you're trying
to turn it into a Sully moment that's
all you're doing
oh really Sully wishes he were me you
want to know what I think of Sully what
else check this out I thought it'd be
softer can you rip that in half for me
my hands are precious
she didn't really try that hard a carbon
I think those that's garbage
I think we're done here all right we're
done really I'm Conan I'm sorry to
interrupt but I was just told to let our
audience know that we're having some
plumbing problems I mean somebody
clogged up all our toilets with DVDs of
the movie Sully damn it sounds like you
guys need a hero
buckle up I'm taking everyone to Tampa
Florida the bathroom
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you